hallo ich meine lieben freund und
herzlich willkommen zu einer sehr kurzen
folge hier ganz kurz auf den server und
zeigt euch wo ich bin jetzt werden sich
die meisten fragen bieten hat was machst
du hier denn hier ist im kino koki und
pinky stinky war ja auch gerade irgendwo
was sollen das ja mein website wiederum
gespuckt und ich konnte wieder eine
folge nicht aufnehmen also was mit
meinem verzierte zeitlos ist keine
ahnung ich hab es kein update ich habe
alles mögliche gemacht ich weiß nicht
was daran wo es daran liegt ich darf
jetzt auch nichts neues machen die
gerade weil das hier grad eine
zusammenfassung ist und zwar bin ich in
der letzten folge die ich gerade
aufgenommen habt könnt ihr bei kif
gerade sehen die ist heute auch bei chip
online gekommen bzw
kommt halt noch bei cash online da seht
ihr das hier alles legitim ist dass ich
hier nicht irgendwelche kacke gemacht
hat oder so nur das einfach meint raps
mindscape aufgenommen hat aus irgend
einem komischen grund ich habe keine
ahnung weiter und macht euch keine
sorgen wir werden in der nächsten folge
natürlich wird dann wieder gemeinsam
sind noch mal alles erzählen was wir
gemacht haben im detail was wir
beschlossen haben was wir aufrüsten
wollen pipapo da wären wir das noch mal
ganz kurz sagen was wird jetzt bisher
gemacht haben ist einfach was in dieser
folge passiert ist ich bin aus diesem
komischen aus dieser komischen burg nach
hause gelaufen und meine ganzen sachen
da noch mal mitgenommen so ein paar
bücherregale abgebauten paar sachen aus
den kisten mitgenommen da waren sachen
drin wie gold blöcke goldene äpfel und
so was alles und sind dann bin ich dann
zurück in die stadt gelaufen habe meine
rüstung hier ein bisschen repariert habe
mich so ein bisschen aus größe die rede
ist hier was hier soll es dabei hab
essen bogen rucksack habe die sachen
sortiert in die kisten reingepackt und
jetzt wollte ich halt mit kev bin ich
mit und mit pacheco bus ca 1000 blöcke
von dahinten bis hierhin eben gereist
und jetzt sind wir hier und gehen jetzt
quasi in die unentdeckten landschaften
die es noch nicht denn die noch nicht
entdeckt wurden die quasi noch schwarzen
auf der karte und dann wollen wir da so
ein bisschen bestand randale machen und
eine ganzen tour machen mit sehen wir
sehr viele dungeons ab käme in der
nächsten folge und das war halt unser
plan wenn ihr noch mal genau als im
detail sehen wollt könnt ihr bei kämpfe
einfach vorbeigucken und sonst tut mir
gar nicht leid diese folge klappt jetzt
als mir mal aufnehmen morgen sollte dann
auch wieder alles klappen wo wir dann
die tour machen
und sonst würde ich sagen
na ja wir sind auch nur menschen so was
kann passieren und menschen das sich auf
ihr verzeiht mir davon würde ich sagen
euch noch wunderschön dach und das
morgen wieder ein hero